what are the most essential items that I
take with me to flow well today I'm
going to show you Drex here from
drexfactor pulley sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today I
am talking about the things that I never
leave home without especially when I'm
about to go out and flow before we dive
in I just want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys and Ultra POI for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Pekka pacquonen thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so real talk I like to travel light I'm
kind of legendary for this and I will
kind of pack down to as few things as
possible but over the years I've found
that there are just five things that I
absolutely cannot do without and I
figured maybe it might not hurt to share
what those things are with you all in
case I have something in my essentials
kit that you might enjoy yourselves or
that you don't even realize that you
need currently so first up this doesn't
technically count as one of my
essentials even though it really is this
is my shoulder bag that I got from a
vendor at Floyd Fest in Virginia about
like 11 or 12 years ago I don't remember
who the vendor was and I'm going to be
so sad when this bag finally reaches the
end of its lifespan so if anybody knows
who this is and hopefully they're still
selling these bags please let me know
down in the comments because I am
definitely interested in making sure
that I have another one waiting when
this one has reached the end of its
lifespan but moving on the real question
what goes into this bag when I go out to
flow I'm so glad you asked
let's go through the list shall we so
first and foremost this is an obvious
one but having a set of poi or the flow
prop of your choice is always helpful
for getting your flow on I have been
really enjoying my favorite POI from
sockboy that's the company run by Katya
stockinova of one day spin Fame they're
just really light they're squishy they
easily fit into a lot of very small
spaces and the weight's really good so
these have been kind of my go-to I plan
on doing an entire video just devoted to
these at some point so be on the lookout
for that but yeah these are my go-to POI
right now especially for daytime
spinning next up my cell phone why is
that uh the biggest reason honestly is
just that I wind up using this to shoot
a lot of video and I don't really want
to carry around a second camera with me
most of the time if I can help it this
is the iPhone 11 Pro I want to say it is
the one that has the three different
cameras and yes I use each of these with
a great deal of of enthusiasm and
frequency this does everything that I
needed to and it is a pleasure for me to
use so I'm sticking with it and if you
all ever want a video with my best tips
for getting the best video that you can
out of your phone please let me know I'd
be happy to do that one all right so
next up
we have a deceptively small but very
very very important little product here
this is what's called a pocket tripod
it's about the same size as a credit
card it is as thick as like two credit
cards but here's what makes this amazing
you fold it out and it becomes
uh this little platform that you can
mount
a phone onto so I can like say stick
this down in the ground and shoot video
of myself uh being able to check myself
on the selfie side of things or I can
switch around the orientation of it so
that I can mount the phone with the
three non-facetime cameras uh pointing
outward and use that to get all sorts of
shot shots as well without a doubt this
is the most compact tripod I have ever
encountered I use it constantly if you
have seen any footage of me spinning
outside it is almost guaranteed that I
was using this it is
one of my favorite tools and ironically
enough it doesn't live in my um in my
bag it lives in my wallet because I have
found it to be so essential that I never
let it be in a place where I don't have
uh immediate access to it at all times
cool so next up I don't know about you
but for me uh having music is definitely
an essential element of flow so I'll
always head out with uh some wireless
headphones or a wireless speaker again
I'm in the Apple ecosystem so I'm just
using standard air pods they get the job
done for me they're super light they're
super convenient uh I think the carrying
case is is quite nice
I don't even remember what brand of
bluetooth speakers these are I'll go
ahead and look it up and link to them
down in the description here but yeah
just uh pretty small these are
surprisingly Loud Like These get the job
done for me not just when I'm out
flowing with my practice POI but also
when I'm spending fire Poise so also
conveniently enough they fit really well
inside of my bag how about that all
right so headphones live over in my
other pocket and that takes us to our
final item my notebook so I will say at
various times that I have definitely had
a thing for getting a little extra with
my notebooks and liking having really
special ones or having artwork on the
cover what have you and as time has gone
on I've kind of gotten to the point
where I need less kind of presence out
of them and I just I need it to exist
and be easy to find so this is just a
mead five-star notebook that I got from
the Target down the street and you know
just a random Bic pen that sits in the
uh sits in The Binding here
um what I use the notebook for like
anytime I have ideas that I want to jot
down ideas for videos ideas for POI
tricks if I'm working on some
choreography and I have something that
I'm worried that the video alone might
not convey I'll write down exactly what
it is
um I just I don't know I'm kind of old
school I like having a more analog
system for writing down ideas and
journaling and all that so having a
notebook on me is pretty essential not
just for my flow but also just like for
me digesting the world around me in
general so into the bag of Wonder it
goes so there you go those are five
items that are essential to my flow and
are basically always on me when I leave
the house so I will go ahead and leave
links to all of these things down in the
description if you want to pick up any
one of them for yourselves I'm also
curious what are your flow Essentials
please leave me a comment and let me
know what do you not leave the house
without whether you're going to flow or
not and if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to leave a like
comment share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going and of course to help
other people find my videos thank you
speaking of thanks this video would not
be possible without the kind support of
all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they along with the people
listed down in the description helps
make this video and all the videos on my
channel possible thank you one and all
for your very generous support and and
if you out there watching are not
currently a supporter and you would like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com drexfactor POI
and signing up there you can get early
access to all of my content as well as a
host of other awesome rewards and even
better you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you cool if
you'd like to check out some of my other
videos on equipment around flow Arts I
will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of said videos down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video right here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get outside
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care peace